Speaker 1: All right, a couple of other quick
stories for you that I wanted to mention.
This is just really funny. Newsmax, the
right wing media network Newsmax, which has
been railing against vaccine protocols,
vaccine requirements, vaccine mandates
for months at this point has notified its
own staff that it will be implementing a
vaccine mandate. This is the vaccine. The vaccine
mandate is coming to Newsmax rights media.
The Conservative News Network informed staffers of
the move Thursday. In a staff wide email obtained
by media aide Newsmax cited the implementation of
COVID rules by OSHA as its reason for instituting
the mandate. The company decree requires all
employees to be fully vaccinated by January 4th,
or they will have to undergo a weekly COVID
test, the email says. To ensure that we are
in compliance, we require all vaccinated
employees submit a copy of their vaccination
card. The move is unlikely to be well-received
by the network's hosts, a number of whom have
denounced vaccine mandates regularly. Let's just
look at just just one or two examples of that,
and I think there is just a brief add here.
We have to get by. Yeah, now this is actually
not that hypocritical, and I'll mention
why in a moment. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: If he did, he pushed America
much closer to full on medical apartheid,
a society that is fundamentally divided into two
tiers Biden used OSHA and other federal powers.
I really should say he abused those powers to
mandate that every single health care worker
in America get vaccinated by early January, and
all employees, all employees in companies with
100 or more workers must get vaccinated
or face weekly testing. But today, now
Speaker 1: I could go on and on with other
examples of this. The truth is that you
could take a position, which is you can be
against it and the hosts can be against it.
But if it's going to be the law, you're going
to comply. And Newsmax could very much take
that position now with the temporary freeze on
the vaccine mandate, which we mentioned earlier.
Maybe Newsmax will go back on this? I don't
know. But what happened to taking a stand?
What happened to I will not comply. What
happened to we will never do that thing,
which we are against because it is their principle
that is violated and will be all that different
stuff. At the end of the day, at minimum, they
seem to be complying. So this is not a commentary
on the legality of it. Newsmax could be saying,
if it's the law, we're going to do it because
we don't want to be testing people daily. This is
not necessarily a comment on the morality of it,
because they could be saying, well, if if it
if, if even if it's immoral, we're going to do
it because it's too difficult otherwise to manage
the testing and vaccination situation here. But
this is a testament to the fact that the vaccine
mandates work. And that's one thing that we've
said time and again. If even Newsmax, which
has been essentially completely against this
in terms of their editorial position, is saying,
but we're still going to do it. It is again proof
that the vaccine requirements work, and
that continues to be a very good sign